oh they know yo Lando Calrissian oh hi
yeah that's me I do my best
leave man zeef how-do big fan big fan
nice to make your acquaintance up menu
is formation all of us man with you no
reason I'm out here in Cloud City dog
man I ain't joking man but you're
ideally though yeah ideally on an ideal
situation I would be doing like what you
doing I'll be up there like in the high
chambers of Cloud City dog I'll see if
it's nice to meet you yo right army cuz
they got me in the Carbonite room right
now son that book right they got me
working with some Pig dudes and whatnot
yeah I ain't no Pig you know and you
ever notice man they ain't a lot of
brothers out here man in space right
it's like they trying to keep us down
man you know III don't think that it's
policy I just think it's really really
difficult to get to this level you've
got to understand the politics of the
Empire and at the same time all the
motivations of the Rebel all that all
that but ideally Tommy ideally what I'm
talking about is like me and you we
should like do something together don't
man cuz if you think about it yo when I
was younger man I used to fly those land
speeders all the time my friends was
like me you should be piloting one of
the x-ray
and so that's like disappointed me
because I got here and they just had me
like cleaning up the r2 units after the
x-wings come in this I gotta go Justin
man I'm saying man have we contact one
another
cuz that's the most important thing that
we contact one another oh look man
ideally though ideally though I would
get to fly somehow like the Millennium
Falcon like that would be cool and yo
let me get you might like my mic on I
got my card in here somewhere
[Music]
you know what zeef just give your
information to Lobot here and we'll be
in touch
no bye man I see how it is I gotta talk
to your mandroid right now man you the
white ass hair why you wearing a cake
though huh where you going to ridges
you
[Music]
have you ever slept with a black guy no
but I really wanted oh way bigger
penises right might be a bit spot-on no
yeah it's a bit spot on it
you
[Music]